ratschläge in die fresse mit friedemann
weise mein ratschlag alles legalisieren
schon allein weil es sonst gar keine
qualitätskontrollen gibt und dass in
deutschland wo doch alles kontrolliert
wird wenn ihr einmal ein pferd in die
lasagne feld ist sechs wochen
staatskrise aber wenn auf dem schulhof
das crack zur hälfte aus zement besteht
es ist ein egal alkohol dagegen wird
immer noch verharmlost faustregel
sie wissen dass sie zu viel trinken wenn
komba sie anruft weil es so viel
regenwald gar nicht gibt wie sie gerade
retten
die gefährlichste einstiegsdroge ist
aber immer noch nikotin
oft brauchen unsichere problem teenagern
uhr und cool zu sein und um von den
älteren in der gruppe akzeptiert zu
werden
so wie hier kommen wir zur nächsten
volksdroge cannabis in meinem
freundeskreis an früher alle gekifft und
die gleichen leute an mittlerweile
richtige berufe und häuser und kinder
und kiffen natürlich gibt es auch
nebenwirkungen vergesslichkeit
konzentrationsschwäche um um nur drei zu
nennen
ach ja viel schlimmer aber noch extreme
stimmungsschwankungen backe noch
gefährlicher sind allerdings
synthetische drogen die führen auf dauer
zu verfolgungswahn angstzuständen und
kompletten realitätsverlust vor zehn
jahren konnte ich nachts salz frau
allein von der disco nach hause gehen
der drogen sind in der politik so
verbreitet manche reden sogar schon von
drogen politik
was viele nicht wissen hitler hat auch
drogen genommen aber bevor jetzt die
kids deshalb glauben dass er cool war
man darf nie vergessen er war auch
vegetarier ratschläge hinweise
[Applaus]